foreign
[Music]
s are going to bomb the UK and so the
authorities decide that all the children
in the cities across the UK need to be
evacuated
my dad was seven and his brother was 11
and their mother had to put them on a
train and just wave goodbye and they
didn't know where they were going who
would be taking them in how long they
would go for none of this stuff and
who knows what kind of damage that did
to families across the country
my grandma decided to turn it into an
adventure
and what she did she gave him a postcard
and she said write the address of where
you end up on this postcard
and if it's horrible
you put one kiss
and I'll come straight down there and
get you back
and if it's okay
you put two kisses
and if it's nice you put three kisses
so it was their secret code
and this first scene that I'm going to
play you now
um takes place on the first night when
they're sitting there by candlelight the
two boys
discussing how many kisses to put on
their postcard
[Music]
are you tired of using bulky old wallets
giving you a bulge where you don't want
it to be my old wallet was massive so it
brought all the ladies to the yard which
was a huge distraction and got in the
way of my esteemed work on trigonometry
reg wallets have an incredible solution
for you this is mine Sleek stylish and
with an industrial look to it can fit 12
cards with cash on the back using a clip
like this one or a strap we've got one
for the whole team I've got one Francis
has one even our producer Anton has one
but he's from Liverpool so he flogged
his on the black market the great thing
about Ridge is that they give you a
lifetime guarantee which means if you
want you can have only one wallet for
the rest of your life Ridge are so
confident in the quality of their
product they will give you 45 days to
test drive their wallets that means you
can get the wallet use it and if you
don't like it you can return it within
45 days because Ridge is such great guys
are going to give you ten percent off
and free worldwide shipping and returns
to take advantage of this incredible
offer go to ridge.com forward slash
trigger that's ridge.com forward slash
trigger and use our special code which
is of course trigger
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constantine kitchen
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with Fascinating
People are brilliant and returning guest
today is a comedian broadcaster and
author Dominic frisbee welcome back to
trigonometry thank you very much
gentlemen thank you for having me back
very excited to be talking to you no
it's great to have you on you've been
working on a lot of different things
since we last interviewed you uh remind
people who haven't seen you on the show
before who are you how are you where you
are what has been the journey through
life that leads you to be sitting here
talking to us okay well I'll summarize
it as quickly as I can I
I always wanted to be a writer and when
I was a young man I saw that the best
writers had all started out as actors
Shakespeare Dickens and many more
besides uh and so I went to drama school
and then when I was at drama school I
found I was very I for some reason I was
always top in radio and uh I so I I've
got a voiceover agent like as soon as I
left so I started out just doing
voiceovers
life doesn't always pan out as you're
intending then I started you have quite
a lot of free time you do voiceovers and
I wrote this comic song and a friend of
mine said he was a music agent I said
can we get this released as a novelty
song and he said no go and do it at my
brother's club which was up the creek
run by Malcolm Hardy and in those days
if you did an open spot they gave you a
paid work so I I did an open spot with
this song and they gave me a paid gig
and suddenly I was a stand-up comedian
it was quite a good life and so that was
what I did stand-up comedy and voice
service and then
because I was working on this other
thing that we're going to talk about in
today's interview and we needed to raise
three to five million quid to make it
happen and I was trying to figure out
how to make it happen
I had to raise his money and this was in
the mid-naughties now so I started a
podcast as a means to meet all these
very rich people that I saw talking on
the internet who made a lot of money and
they were all talking about gold at the
time in Commodities and all this kind of
thing and and as I'm sure you know from
doing podcasts it's just it's amazing
how many people you meet and the how
much you learn just by talking to all
these people how much information you
absorb but one of the people I
interviewed was this woman called Marin
Somerset Webb who was Financial Times
journalist and she ran money week and
she said oh we need people like you to
come and write for us and so I she
started they just gave me a column
writing for money week and I was like I
don't really know what I'm talking about
and she was like it's fine just right
and um and so suddenly I was a financial
writer so I've had this weird double
life as as a sort of comedian author
songwriter and um a financial writer and
I sort of the bizarrely it works and so
that's how I've ended up where I am well
you're a man of many skills uh but the
reason we wanted to have you back is
you've got this very interesting very
exciting story to tell I don't want to
talk over it a little bit so why don't
you tell us what you're up to okay so
this actually was something that my dad
wrote my dad was quite a well-known
writer guy called Terence frisbee died a
few years ago and he wrote this story
about his time as an evacuee during
World War II and he wrote it and it was
a radio drama on BBC Radio 4 in the
1980s immensely popular and it was like
it got broadcast more than any other
radio drama got broadcast that year or
something and it won all these Awards
and it got letters from people who'd
been evacuated in Germany
to escape English bombs and also people
who've been evacuated in Russia so the
story of children being evacuated was a
huge subject and I fell in love with it
I was only about 19 or 20. and then he
tried to get it made into a film for
many years and I think he got an option
by Ken Loach but you know it got stuck
in development hell and then in the
early noughties
um a chance encounter on a golf course
this guy from a regional theater in
Barnstable just said have you got a
project for me and Dad said actually I
do and he was talking to his friend
who'd always been going you should turn
this thing into a stage Musical and so
they did it as a stage Musical
and then
and it was just the best thing I ever
saw and that was why I started to try
and work out how to raise three to five
minute quid to bring this thing into the
West End
so that's the sort of background to this
project and then during the lockdown and
dad had died at this point and I was
just like
um
I've been going through his stuff and
the script and the CD was I taken it
home he was just sitting me every day
I'd be sat on my desk during the
lockdown and this script would be
looking at me and I I was going if I
don't make this happen nobody's going to
make it happen
so during the lockdown
um I decided I didn't have the means to
turn it into Stage version obviously
covered and all the rest of it didn't
have the money or the means to turn it
into a film and it's not just making the
film you need powerful allies
Distributors and so on to get the film
scene but I did have the means to turn
it into an audio project
so I set to work and we made an audio
project of this musical four hours long
I rewrote load of the songs with my
songwriter who it turned out his
um Dad had also been evacuated during
the war so he had a similar experience
and so and then because it was the
lockdown and nobody was working we were
able to get quite big stars involved in
the project John Owen Jones who's a big
like the greatest ever Jean
um
in Les Mis and various others and
then by chance encounter we were
supposed to record it in one studio and
they totally started breaking our balls
about covid and everyone had to be two
meters apart and we were like well the
orchestra can't sit to me and all this
stuff so we ended up changing Studios
and I just phoned around the studios at
the last minute and and I phoned up Abby
Road and they said well we've just had a
cancellation
um and if you like you can come and
uh record it here and we'll give it to
you at Cost because the conductors got
to go into
um quarantine for two weeks so we ended
up recording the whole thing at Abbey
Road and various other Studios as well
Abbey Road you know Beatles Fame song so
that's the sort of background to this
project now I'm just going to tell you
the the story
the first like 20 minutes of the musical
and then I'm going to play you the one
video we've made of the musical and
we're going to see what your reaction is
okay so we're in it's
um 1940 1940.
and
last of the soldiers have just been
evacuated from Dunkirk
World War II and they know the blitz is
coming the Germans are going to bomb the
UK and so the authorities decide that
all the children in the cities across
the UK need to be evacuated
and I think am I going to say it's
either 4 million or 8 million kids
um between the ages of 4 and 13 were
evacuated to escape the bombing from the
cities to the countryside it was the
biggest wholesale of movement in our
country's history
and they were sent kids were sent from
their families so you can imagine
my dad was seven and his brother was 11
and their mother had to put them on a
train and just wave goodbye and they
didn't know where they were going who
would be taking them in how long they
would go for none of this stuff
and
who knows what kind of damage that did
to families across the country some
people had happy experiences and other
people had terrible experiences
and it's just an incredible story and
it's not a story that you hear told very
often
so
um my dad was seven his brother was 11.
they're at home in southeast London
and their mum
comes in and they have a little label on
with their name
and a gas mask and a bag with you know a
change of underwear and some pajamas
and dad and his brother Jack
um are going where are we going mum and
she doesn't know
and so she's they walk up to the station
um
and as they go into the station uh all
the other kids
from their school join them
and there's this incredible crowds and
the whole school puts their kids onto
the train
and just waves goodbye
right that's you can imagine the
terminal
and in order to
lighten the situation for them
my grandma decided to turn it into an
adventure
and what she did she gave him a postcard
and the postcard said dear mum and dad
arrived safe and well loved Jack and
Terry she gave this postcard she said
write the address of where you end up on
this postcard
and if it's horrible
you put one kiss
and I'll come straight down there and
get you back
and if it's okay
you put two kisses
and if it's nice you put three kisses
okay so it's their secret code
and so she turned the whole thing into
an adventure form and they go so they go
onto the train
and it's just they're two School
teachers and all the kids on the train
and they're sent they get on the train
at uh Deptford
and then this the train goes across
Southeast London and it just keeps on
going and going and going and eventually
they end up in Cornwall
in a tiny tiny village at Liskeard and
then they're all put on buses and fanned
off to different villages in the region
of of Cornwall
and dad and his brother and about 50 or
60 other kids were herded into the
um village hall in this tiny village
called dob walls dobbles and double boys
they were herded into the village hall
and they were all made to stand there
and then all the locals just walked
round and said I'll take that one there
I'll take that one there so it was like
a cattle market they were just picked
out at random and then they went and
signed their name and they were sent off
to go with these locals
and dad and his brother were taken in by
this Welsh couple who'd moved down to
Cornwall and he had been a soldier in
World War One
they would eventually learn and you can
just imagine these strange accents these
strange people what a traumatic
experience that was for the kids
but anyway
dad was taken in by this Welsh couple
um Auntie Rose and Uncle Jack and Uncle
Jack had
um this was a huge thing people tried to
separate dad and his brother and they
were like we have to stay together we
have to stay together this was a thing
we have to stay together that was the
instruction their mum had given him Dan
and his brother were taken in by this
Welsh couple and now he had been a
soldier in World War one and he'd been
in he was only five foot high and he'd
been in this regiment called the Welsh
bantams
which had come up against the Prussian
guard who were all over six foot and
they were all involved in this massacre
the mammoths would Massacre where only
17 of them survived 17 and he went back
to his village and he was the only man
from The Village to go back
and so as a result him and his wife they
just had to leave the village because
All the Other Women looking at him like
that was just too much for them so
they'd moved down to Cornwall and he was
now a plate layer on the Great Western
Railway
dad and his brother Love Trains steam
trains and they went back to this house
there was no electricity
um and they walked in and there was a
canary
in a cage a cat asleep by the fire they
went into the garden tiny little Railway
Cottage they went into the garden there
was chickens in the yard and a pig
outdoor privies
and they had this son Gwen who was sort
of very funny and sang all the time and
outside the house there was this huge
Valley with woods and rivers to Dam and
then the railway at the end of their
garden with the trains going past
and
they thought
they had died and gone to heaven they
thought it was fantastic and this first
scene that I'm going to play you now
um takes place on the first night when
they're sitting there by candlelight the
two boys
um discussing how many kisses to put on
their postcard
how many kisses I vote three what would
mum and dad think of it here don't know
no electricity they wouldn't like that I
don't care there's no bathroom I don't
care
[Music]
only mom is going to know
[Music]
[Music]
if we put lesson three mum and dad will
think it's rotten here they'll be
worried yeah well there's the trains
they're good and the station right next
to us that's terrific hey wait I've just
remembered hence what about hens egg
stupid real eggs not that horrible
powdery stuff
X for you X for me eggs for breakfast
[Music]
but don't you see the more kisses we put
the more happy they're going to be yeah
it's terrific Kim really isn't it like
being on holiday only there's no sea we
don't have to stop at four let's do
hundreds yeah
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
and surely you can find a kiss
[Music]
night Jack night's Harry
look at them fast asleep
and they've covered the card in kisses
night night boys
that's amazing yeah I really really
enjoyable
and it's also powerful as well
because
you in many ways you know we mollycodile
children in our generation and
but what these young boys had to go
through is something that we can't none
of us can comprehend number one and
number two certainly not children being
torn away from your families going to
places in the country that you don't
know of that you don't know about it's a
completely different way of life
it's it's very powerful and did that
have a profound effect on your father
I think so
I think so he used to talk about it and
that whole generation
most of them are dead now they're still
you know few in their late 80s and 90s
but they all used to talk about it and
yeah as I said some had good experiences
like Dad and others had had horrible
times
and basically but that story basically
just tells the whole of
their time during the war that's what
you just saw there is like 20 minutes up
up to 20 minutes in so though so he had
quite a positive experience on the whole
he did but I can't see how it didn't
mess him up
you know he spent four years down there
from seven to eleven four years
wow and other than the occasional
postcard or letter would they have any
contact with I think mum and dad came
down a couple of times because there are
some photos of them down there but yeah
four years I think those who had
unhappier experiences
went back sooner but basically
he didn't go home until after they
started invading Sicily because the man
Gwen who was the son of Auntie Rose and
Uncle Jack went off to fight in Sicily
and was killed wow wow
so
did he ever talk about it his
experiences he did but most of it's in
he you know he wrote a book about it so
everything was distilled into that book
but yeah he talked about it a lot
the impact that must have on a young
child
in an old country it's a whole country
and the impact that must have and not
seeing your parents for four years and
the impact on the parents
some people never found their parents
again because they will have died or
just lost contact so there were some
children who never found their parents
they were some just ended up staying
forever where they went
and let me know one or two not not
I mean not everyone the majority would
have gone home and when we talk about
the impact I'm curious what you would
say the impact is because I imagine that
one of the things we associate with your
father's generation is this kind of
stoicism that perhaps people now like to
hearken back to so I don't know whether
that's accurate of course but going
through things like that as both parents
of children and children themselves when
we say impact what do you what do you
think it was
I think people then would definitely
mentally tougher than we are now
and you know they had no mobile phones
had no means of communicating
and they were literally going into the
unknown
um I think they were much more trusting
of authority
than they are now and one of the
questions you asked me Constantine I
remember when we were talking a couple
of weeks ago you said could
that happen now
that that people would send their kids
off to just go stay with a total
stranger who there's no way of vetting
them they're only vetted locally by
their communities you know there's no
they haven't got their little
certificate that proved they aren't a
pedophile or something you know
um
would we would that be able to happen
now
and
because
you know Britain was so much more
monocultural than whereas now it's much
more Multicultural and so between the
various
um cultures that we have there's perhaps
they're not the same levels of trust
that there were then and
you know Cornwall particularly you know
it's the end of Britain
but it it you know they spoke a
different language in Cornwall they
didn't then they'd already stopped
speaking it but you know it's culturally
very different from the rest of Britain
and
um
you know anyone outside of Cornwall is a
foreigner let alone a Londoner it also
had a big impact on the towns they went
to because you know the village kids
what happened is all the
you know the London kids all came and
the land they were better at sport they
were cleverer you know when they had
Village kids against the vacuous kids
football matches or cricket matches
whatever the village kids would always
get destroyed the the londoners just
thought the village kids were stupid The
Village kids resented these new
newcomers it you know created so much
Social turmoil in the places that they
went to they were dad said there was
fights all the time Village Kids versus
the vacu kids
you know any excuse for a fight and um
you know they'd arrange these huge
fights down in the woods or if it was
Winter they'd arrange huge snowball
fights and
so they were never so a lot of them
weren't really accepted in the community
then
I guess some of them weren't some of
them weren't
yeah
um like all these things there would
have been some people who opened up
their arms to them yeah and other people
who didn't want them there at all and
were there some who just didn't who's
who kept their children in London
because they wanted their children near
or was that not really an option at that
time
I guess there were one or two but
like do you remember how scared everyone
was when kovid first started and their
first lockdown yeah yeah and okay so
let's just say you know we've got all
this tension at the moment with Russia
and Ukraine and by the way I played it
that scene to a load of people the first
hour of the musical to a load of people
in the car just as Russia was invading
Ukraine
and everyone said exactly the same
thing's happening in Ukraine now with
the massive accuration away particularly
from the Eastern Ukrainian cities so
something very similar happened in
Ukraine and you know you saw them they
just wrote their names on a label and
sent them off into the unknown but if
you just knew that Britain's about to be
bombed
and just and and I'm paralleling with
that fear of the unknown that was
covered when it first happened Britain
London's about to be bombed you need to
go for your own safety it would take
someone of a very contrarian mindset to
go no my kids are safer here with me
while you know Germany's bombing us and
also as well at that point although I'm
not sure how how aware they would be of
this fact Germany were very much in the
ascendancy at that point oh yeah
it was only the decision to uh invade
Russia that did for Hitler in if if he
hadn't invaded Russia you know America
stayed out and Britain was done for he
probably would have won
hey Francis what do you think is the
best way to advertise a business that's
easy all you need to do is spend shed
loads of cash on an advert that's going
to be promoted on a dying medium-like TV
then simply sit back and watch all your
hard-earned money disappeared down the
toilet what about advertising with
trigonometry why would I do that when I
can advertise on itv3 for the measly sum
of 20 grand and be watched by six people
because trigonometry now has over 350
000 subscribers across the different
platforms and gets 2 million views and
downloads a month that's right you can
place an advert with us and we'll
promote your brand on one of our
episodes your advert will be written by
two professional comedians yeah that's
right we're hiring two professional
comedians
when we make our ads funny and engaging
to the point where some people say the
ads are their favorite parts of the show
yeah we probably shouldn't admit that
mate all you need to do is contact us on
marketing at
triggerpod.co.uk that's marketing a
triggerpod DOT Co dot UK advertise with
us and we'll get your business canceled
now and what do you think the because
I've never really heard these stories at
all I didn't really even know that this
was a thing particularly uh what what do
you think the impact of that was on on
society going forward because these are
obviously very significant things for
young people to go through at that age
and a whole generation of children would
have grown up into adults from that
experience
well I I look at
Britain in maybe 1911 or something like
that at the sort of the height of the
Empire when we really
produced all these amazing individuals
and we led the world in science and
philosophy and math you know every thing
in the world and
how quickly we descended from that
greatness
um relative to other countries in the
world and it was the two Wars
first world war and and then you know
people give Chamberlain a hard time for
being an appeaser but I think he lost
five of his brothers in the first world
war and that was why he was like we
can't do this again why he was so
reluctant to go into the second world
war it's a side of Chamberlain that you
never hear
and so but
I think it was yet another thing
that
you know destroyed the fabric of
Britain's greatness it was just yet
another episode in this sort of ongoing
destruction because ultimately we just
lost so many people and we used to have
big families seven eight ten people and
now you know it's one or two kids and
you know it all starts with family and
if you destroy the family and this had a
terrific impact on British families and
you one thing we're never really aware
of is the fact that rationing it didn't
just end in 1945 it carried on for a
number of years and in fact there was a
lot of London and a lot of cities like
Liverpool and Birmingham that were just
that had just Rubble for many years
afterwards so this idea that we you know
bounced back and everything was fine we
were broken from the second world war
for a long time yeah we were and it's
interesting that the rationing thing the
two the kids talk about it how excited
they were to eat real eggs yeah and we
would take it for granted and and you
know meet
the you could get a little bit of it in
the country for obvious reasons but yeah
rationing was and sweets and you know
there just was stuff wasn't in the shops
we take so much of that uh the abundance
that we have today for granted that's
one of the reasons I love talking to
older people because I think I've talked
about in the fall probably an episode of
Charles UD uh the historian about my
family's history in Ukraine I always
bring this up my grandmother uh who's uh
96 uh she lived through uh you know she
lived through decolocation uh stalinism
then the Nazi occupation and she was she
always tells me how uh during the war
her and her girlfriends they would have
a bet uh on whether they would ever eat
real bread again that was the sort of
experiences that people were having but
Dominic you mentioned family I'm curious
as well you know there's obviously a
very deep personal connection here for
you with your dad and being able to
finish something after he's gone what
was it like working on this for you well
it's it's been my life's mission
for 25 years to to make this musical
exist
um because and it's not just people are
looking and go you you know you love
your dad of course I love my dad and but
it it's it's I'm sure you see this with
comedians or something who you think are
brilliant and nobody notices them and
they seem to spend their whole lives
just not being ignored and I just know
how good this story is and how brilliant
the songs are and how powerful and it's
funny and it's it's got this huge
profound message to it and and it's also
makes you laugh it makes you cry I just
wanted to make this thing exist
it's it's that's it's literally and it's
like if I didn't do it nobody would and
yeah so how difficult is it to make
something like this happen to take a
musical from
you know the the writing the music
putting it together and then taking it
to the West End
it's it can be really easy and it can be
impossible and you know it like if you
look at take the example of six uh about
The Six Wives of Henry VII
I think the two it was written by two
students or one was a student one wasn't
and I think they wrote it in like two
weeks it was six songs one for each of
the wives of Henry VII they did it as an
Edinburgh show did very well in
Edinburgh Suddenly It's a West End show
everyone's raving about it it's
syndicated all the way around the world
I know the guy does the pr quite well
and he says he thinks that no musical
ever has made as much money as quickly
as six and I think it start and that and
that is despite the headwinds that are
covered
you know that had to be close so if you
if you just hit something and it flies
it can be incredibly easy and then for
other people they could we could you
could spend your whole life trying to
get something on and nobody cares so it
can be impossible but you need to to the
the problem with putting this show on in
the West End is it's got 18 kids in it
so you would probably need three sets of
kids
uh so that's a logistical problem but
it's bizarre musicals with kids tend to
do very well Oliver The Sound of Music
Matilda Matilda Billy Elliot you know
people like stories with kids but they
are problematic so it's got a big cast
it helps if you want to do a West End
show if there's some kind of brand
awareness before you do it so that's why
we have a lot of jukebox jukebox
musicals
um
it helps you know and you see a lot of
revivals of the sound of music or
Oklahoma whatever it is and this had
none of that and it didn't have a big
star attached to it so that was always
headwind rather than tailwind and it
makes it very hard but
you know the beauty of audio
is it's cheaper to make and
I'm not convinced that peop people seem
to want to see musicals rather than hear
them
um bizarrely but at least I know it now
exists and so you upload it to the
internet and it's kind of permanent and
so that makes me happy I'm sure and when
you say it exists how can people listen
to it watch it because that was not only
beautifully sung and whatever but it's
also beautifully filmed and acted too
yeah well most that's the only video we
made to to promote it and but it shows
you how it could look if Netflix or
someone would turn it into a TV program
but kisses on a postcard is the website
and
um you can either you can just get it on
your podcast app you know Apple podcast
you just type in kisses on a postcard
and you'll get the the four hour it's
four and a half hours I didn't I was
gonna make it two hours and then I just
thought you know what people like really
long audio books people like your show
they're like Joe Rogan they're like long
stuff so I just thought I'm just putting
the whole thing in so four and a half
hours and um so you would listen to it
in half hour chunks the same way you
might listen to a series or something
um so yeah you can find an Apple podcast
Spotify wherever you listen to podcasts
kiss it on a postcard if you want CDs
you can buy
um CDs as well old school and
I mean even just doing the audio version
it cost me a lot of money and I'm gonna
I'm gonna make a big loss on it but I
don't care yeah because I just wanted to
make it happen that's the problem are
you stick it up into podcasts you upload
it and
there's no existing brand so I can't do
yeah I can't advertise all the things
that you advertise and so on because
that took you several years to get this
was on a postcard sponsored by manscape
I was thinking South Bank Investments
it's very it's very interesting what
we're talking about and particularly
you know the road to the West End and we
were saying that like how does that work
how do you take a show
and then get it transferred to the West
End you it's
it
a lot of stuff starts in Edinburgh
a lot of stuff starts in the provinces
that put on a show one of the regional
theaters or in a fringe theater and it
it captures a Zeitgeist and people get
interested in it grows from there
sometimes a producer will have a vision
sometimes a big star will come along and
say I want to do a musical and they'll
find a musical that's a vehicle for the
big star it happens in any number of
different ways but there are only so
many theaters in the rest end and to get
a show on in the West End requires
extraordinary amounts of capital to do
this now this show would certainly more
than 5 million quid probably near 10
million now today's prices it's an
insane amount of money you would need
investors Angels they're normally called
theater investors it's famously high
risk there's been all sorts of musicals
made about people losing money in
musicals you know it's it's a famous way
to lose your money but some of the
biggest Fortunes in history of Andrew
Lloyd Webber Cameron McIntosh two of the
richest people in the country who made
their Fortune made their money in the
West End so it's
it's like it's like how does a bit you
know how do you become Dave Chappelle or
Chris Rock or something
you know
it's
for whatever reason you get the TV gig
at the right time you're already good
and then people want more of it and
stuff just happens for you and you catch
a you catch a tailwind and it happens
for some and it doesn't happen for other
stuff and do you think that in this case
I mean one of the things that I wanted
to speak with you about is history
because I this is obviously something
that is now history essentially for most
people and Francis and I we've had
plenty of historians on the show we are
both fascinated by history I think if
you don't understand history you don't
understand the present or the future at
all
are we the expression of those who do
not understand the past are doomed to
repeat it or something like that I think
a better one is those and those who do
are doomed to watch others repeat
which is I think to a large extent what
we're living through now uh but what I
wanted to ask you is do you think
there's an audience out there a bit
that's big enough for something that's
about history in a world that's obsessed
with right here click click click two
minute Twitter clip all of this right
here right now do you think there's
enough people who are still interested
in in history I have absolutely no doubt
you know this this is a is a you know
not every drama or has to be set in the
present day you know it it's set in the
past it's set in World War II but it's
not a history lesson it's a story about
The Adventures of two kids who leave
there who are separated from their
family you know Harry Potter is a story
about a kid who's separated from his
family and sent into an unwell known
well this is a story about two kids who
have sent from their family in London to
a tiny village in Cornwall and it's
about the stories of their Adventures
over four years in this tiny corny
Village and it's got laughter it's got
tears it's got drama it's got good songs
it's got fights it's got stories it's
got everything you want in a drama and
so I have no doubt that there there is a
um an appetite for it because if you
think about I think it's the most
popular musical now which is Hamilton
Hamilton is based on his historical
historical events yeah it is and one of
the side effects of Hamilton is you do
take an interest in Alexander Hamilton
who you might not previously have known
about I personally don't like the
portrayal of Thomas Jefferson who I
think is a rather a heroic figure in the
past and I don't like the way he was
portrayed in Hamilton but but yeah Les
Mis is about a historical event you know
a lot of great musicals are and do you
think one of the challenges might be
because and I really like theater but
the more I've I've looked at theatrical
culture and theater and musicals it does
seem to be more and more
cross-pollination with Americans so you
know there's a show that on Broadway
that's a hit they bring it over here and
in many ways it just squeezes out our
own talent doesn't it
yeah I'm afraid that's true
um a lot of stuff that does well on
Broadway will come over here that's
another route into the West End that I
didn't mention before
um
I'm afraid
we as the English are lucky that we have
English because
but it's also in many ways our downfall
because
um
you know if we had a a different
language that wasn't an international
language I'm sure it'd be better to
preserve our own things but because we
have English we tend to get diluted a
little bit by America but particularly
musically but um
you know the American Hollywood American
Theater American Media
you know it's just an all-powerful
machine and so it it it affects
you know drama and theater and
everything everywhere
um the
and you know the entertainment in
businesses are there's a lot more people
who want to be famous actors than there
is room for famous actors at the top
there's a lot more people who want to be
writers there's a lot more people who
want to be podcasters than there is you
know then there are people who actually
want to listen to podcasts if you if you
know what I mean and so it's a Cutthroat
ruthless industry and you've got to be
hard and you've got to be good and
you've got to take the knocks and you've
got to grab the opportunities when they
come and all those you know feel good
messages the entertainment is ruthless
and there's a lot of competition and and
then you do see the stuff that gets on
particularly on on a lot of Telly and
you're like
how did that get on yeah when there's so
much good stuff that's just queuing up
and doesn't get noticed how did it get
on
how do they get on TV
I think if if we're going to moan about
TV comedy I think a lot of TV comedy is
owned by about two or three agents and
they seem to control a lot of it
um I think producers don't set the net
wide enough I think there's a lack of
risk taking in producers they don't want
to take the risk on a new guy that get
this guy because he was the guy from
such and such and therefore you know
it's the commissioning process
um against you know YouTube or whatever
which is just a free-for-all
but there's all sorts of risks but but
there's
people in commissioning don't take huge
risks a lot of the time they don't take
huge risks and whenever one of the
things and it's hard it's it's hard to
make entertainment yeah and given some
of the costs involved that you're
talking about with putting on the west
end so for example I mean I can see why
people would be somewhat risk-averse
with five million quid I've I've got you
I need 10 million Quinn Constantine what
are you going to tell me to put this
thing on or you could go and do Oklahoma
and have you know Hugh Jackman in the
lead role right what are you gonna what
are you gonna put on yours yes that's
why it's terrible with money yeah but
there is a there is a beauty to musical
theater in that you can have a hit I
think it was Lionel bar who was a
perfect example of this he created and
wrote Oliver which is a huge Global hit
success transferred all around the world
they made a film of it and then he made
Robin Hood a few years afterwards which
sent him completely bankrupt like I
don't understand Lionel bar because
Oliver just contains brilliant song
after brilliant song after brilliant
song it's obviously a fantastic story as
well and it's a fantastic Musical and
everything else that guy did in his life
was not very good and yet Oliver was so
brilliant and it was like he took his
whole life and it's like he did a deal a
fast impact or something he says give me
all the talent that I'm gonna have over
my lifetime I'm just going to put all in
this one Musical and um yeah I don't
understand how
the same guy can create one thing that's
so good and other stuff that isn't but
that's the magic of it isn't it you know
it's that lightning in the bottle moment
yeah
because it's very few people he did in
that he caught lightning in the bottle
it's exactly the right and the rest of
the time there was no there was no
lightning only sunshine because we look
like we're saying you know if you've got
other people's money and you have to
justify to them why we're going to put
it into this unknown musical where there
is no where there are no stars or you
can take a show that's crushing it on
Broadway like Book of Mormon and it's
already got a lot of heat behind it yeah
Book of Mormon is brilliant yes but
those two guys are already well known
um
I think another problem quite
interesting I've been thinking about a
bit recently is if you like you doing
this show are directly answerable to
your customers you have a direct
relationship with your customers and if
people start watching the show you're
out of business
um a lot of organizations and this
applies to the NHS and also to the BBC
they're not directly answerable to the
customers the customers pay to the
middleman whether the TV tax or your tax
and then that's given to the NHS or to
the BBC so that customer relationship I
mean you find a lot of people in the BBC
often actually have contempt for their
viewers and they think they know better
than their viewers and certainly in the
NHS you know the customer can't hold the
doctor to account in the same way that
you know
I can hold the guy who sells me the shoe
shop account or whatever it's a bad
analogy but you get my point there isn't
that Direct Customer relationship and I
don't think that leads to Quality
Service if if the provider is directly
accountable accountable to the customer
in a traditional customer seller
relationship then there's a lot more
accountability and that results in
better content which is why I'm glad
we've had you on to talk about it and
you've put it out as an audio that
people can access and enjoy because at
the end of the day uh I mean obviously
the three of us can spend hours whining
about the BBC and there's plenty to
complain about but the reality is we
live in a different world now and in
that world you put stuff out and people
like it or you put stuff out and they
don't and you live and die by that sword
rather than some guy deciding that you
are the right person or not the right
person I mean the destruction of the
gatekeeping industry has been one of the
greatest Boons of this technological
Revolution that we're living through and
I'm delighted about that that people
like us now have those opportunity to
actually stick by what we believe you
thought this needed making you put it
out there people are going to listen to
it and they're either going to enjoy or
not and that is the Judgment of the
public with which we all live I could
not agree more Constantine and we have
we have to be so grateful in this day
and age for technology because suddenly
with one phone with one phone you've got
a the kit that would have cost you two
three five million dollars 25 years ago
just with one phone and it has
democratized anything and I'm like with
everything I do it's just like I can't
be bothered to sending in letters to the
BBC begging them to notice me and put on
my show I'm just gonna go and make the
song that I want to make I'm just going
to go and do whatever it is I want to do
and if people like it great and if they
don't well you know and I just think
that has created so many opportunities
and
it has improved the quality of content
if you listen to people 15 years ago
nobody wants anything that's more than
three minutes and then suddenly podcasts
came along and people wanted five hour
conversations and they're like what and
you know nobody would have commissioned
cat videos and I think cat videos are
the most and nobody would commission you
know some spotty bloke to give you
instructions about how to you know
repair the the handle on your mug or
something but those how-to videos are
the most watched things on YouTube and
instructional and they're so helpful
yeah and and you want the spotty guy
that knows about China fragments you
don't want
um you know
Emily matless on mugs
no you don't well Dominic that's why you
know I'm excited about this I think it's
great I think people in our space
frankly need to I mean look we spent a
long time whining about all this stuff
we've whined our way to wherever we are
now I think it's up to us to start
building things to creating things
that's why I'm excited about kisses on a
postcard I I think it's going to be
great I can't wait to listen to it I I
hope our audience will do as well
um and uh with that before we ask you
our usual last question is there
anything you wanted to add or say just
thank you very much for the opportunity
kisses on a postcard.com please listen
and um I hope you enjoy
and the final question we always end our
interviews with is what's the one thing
we're not talking about but we really
should be
it's funny the last time I did this show
you asked me that question and I said
race and I talked to you know defining
what it actually is racism and then
about two or three months later the
whole BLM riots and all that kicked it's
his fault yeah exactly you started I
just want to say I'm sorry yeah and uh
the
so and and it was quite an awkward
conversation I remember I broke out into
a sweat but it was
it was premonitionary I was right that's
what he's trying to say so here's here's
the thing this is not so much of an
issue thing it's just something that I
think is happening
or could happen
and that is
the and it's where I think podcasting is
going and that is the power of audio
now when if you think we only invented
writing
as a means to transfer information over
distance and over time you know if I
need to transfer words beyond what you
can hear in that actual present that's
why we invented writing but the brain
the human brain actually absorbs words
through the air better than it does off
the page and I think once you understand
that you understand this extraordinary
boom we've seen in podcasting audio
books and all the rest of it the the the
the and they say that radio is the most
visual medium it's a it's a lovely old
expression
because you you created all and with
that in mind I think where media is
going
is do you remember you're probably too
young but in the 70s there was this huge
boom in the concept album
yeah so there was the War of the Worlds
was probably the most famous example
dram audio dramatization of of the War
of the Worlds by H.G Wells but there
were many other concept albums the wall
and there was this huge booming concept
albums which was sort of spoken word
music drama Bowie sort of play with it a
lot and just imagine stuff and I think
I hope that this podcasting audio boom
moves into a sort of
people start really experimenting with
music Audio Drama
um audio books and it all sort of comes
together and we get these incredibly
visual audio pieces I I think we could
be going in that direction and I think
that would be good for art I mean that
was a lot less stressful than what you
said last
I'm like where's he gonna go with this
oh no it's this long podcast with a bit
of music cool yes that it's all going to
be race based
fantastic there you go uh Dominic thank
you so much we're going to ask you a
couple of questions that our audience
have submitted for uh locals and only
they will get to see that so make sure
you join locals but for now uh tell
everybody just remind everybody where
they can find uh the musical where they
can find you online Etc and then we will
we'll go and ask you those couple of
questions so you can find me at Dominic
frisbee.com and my Twitter handle is at
Dominic Frisbee and but the the website
for the uh show is kisses on a
postcard.com the show is called kisses
on a postcard so stick kisses on a
postcard into Spotify or apple podcast
whatever you'll find it but kisses on a
postcard.com it all starts there thanks
Dominic and thank you guys for watching
and listening we will see you very soon
on locals and then afterwards with
another brilliant episode like this one
or raw show all of them go out 7 P.M UK
time and for those of you who like your
trigonometry on the go it's also
available as a podcast take care and see
you soon guys
I've heard Dominic talk about how the
housing crisis is much more than simple
lack of new homes being built can you
explain further about what else is
causing the problems in Supply and what
more importantly can be done about it
yes I can
[Music]